It's interesting.
It's it's feels like one of those things where even just two white guys talking
about this in 2020, like we need to be in a bunker. We need to be protected.
We can't even say what we're saying. I'm just going to give them a problem.
I'm going to give him my Jerry Springer, Yani long day thought of the day,
you gotta stop judging people on their person and
revering or hating people based on ad hominem attacks.
Listen to what they say. Cherry pick what you like, create your own thing.
Whether they be liberal or conservative and fix it, baby,
because life is a farmer's market and you can't just leave what cookies I will
say. I will say one thing about you is even though you have one eye,
you always do see two sides. I see two sides with my one.
I had a meeting with the producers and we say, you know what?
Because you're the Dennis Rodman of this podcast. Whatever's going,
we just got to go with the flow bed. If you shut. If you come in with naked,
we play, we do the podcast, whatever you do, we do. We don't ask questions.
We don't judge. If you come in with a guy and you say, this is my husband,
we go, that's his husband today guy, because if we looked at your DMS,
would you say you are the most equal opportunity DMR? Cause I,
because you're,
your DMS proves how much of a lover of all races you are.
I'm a lover of all races.
You will see my DMS on telling you it will not discriminate against color,
creed, or religion at all. As long as you got a big Dick, you're getting a deed.
He'll take whatever. Cause your Dick is like the statue of Liberty.
I'm going to call your Dick Ellis Island. Give me your tired, your hungry,
whatever. Cause it's what it is because you everybody. everybody cuts my hair,
carts a Nazi. My a black Panther.
We really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boards where things get really
wide. Well.